ils sont de nouveau devant le collège
pour manifester eux ce sont les parents
d'élèves inquiet de ne pas être entendus
nous propose qu'une seule classe de 5e
l'année prochaine et seront 33 donc
c'est ingérable pour les enfants enfin
pour les profs et donc on n'est pas
content on aimerait deux classes l'année
prochaine cette semaine on est en
collège mort c'est à dire qu aucun élève
n'est venu cette semaine et on remercie
les profs d'ailleurs qui sont en grève
aujourd'hui une opération collège mort
qui a débuté lundi dernier avec une
grande manifestation dans les rues
d'arnay le duc aujourd'hui le mouvement
des parents reçoit le soutien des
enseignants qui se sont mis en grève ce
jour il dennis la baisse continue de la
dotation horaire on a perdu plus de 1000
heures année sur sur deux ans cette
année en organe des élèves on a de quoi
faire deux classes de 5e 33 élèves pour
une classe et c'est trop et on a
continué à nous enlever des heures le
collège d'arnay le duc souffre de
réduction d'horaires depuis plusieurs
années ce territoire bénéficie pourtant
de soutien de l'état le maire de la
commune solidaires du mouvement des
parents d'élèves ne tolère plus la
dégradation des conditions
d'enseignement
moi je souhaite réellement que on est
des perspectives parce que d'un côté
l'état nous aide en mettant en place des
dispositifs et puis d'un autre il ya ce
grignotage permanent comme un rouleau
compresseur de l'éducation nationale qui
nous enlève progressivement des heures
fois un moratoire pendant la durée du
quinquennat peut-être en disant voilà
ces zones là elles sont prioritaires il
faut les aider et on ne ferme plus deux
classes pendant les cinq ans à venir la
directrice académique des services de
l'éducation nationale nous a confirmé
que le sujet faisait l'objet d'un suivi
attentif
une audience est prévue le 4 juillet au
rectorat pour faire un dernier point sur
les effectifs